the surface area of a sphere is 4 Pi *
its radius squared exactly 4 * the area
of a circle with the same radius why
Archimedes had a very beautiful proof
that this surface area is the same as
the area of a cylinder enclosing that
sphere assuming you disregard those
circular caps the basic idea is to
compare the area of small patches of
area on that sphere to that of the
shadow that such a patch would cast on
the cylinder from a light that's at the
same height on the z-axis the details
are too long for a short that's what we
cover in the full video but the upshot
is that you can prove that the area of
this sphere equals that of this cylinder
label but that's something that you can
unwrap into a rectangle where one side
length corresponds to the circumference
2 pi * R and the other corresponds to
the height which is 2 * the radius this
gives us the 4K r^ s that we're looking
for and if you're also familiar with a
similar trick that relates the area of a
circle to a certain triangle there's a
visceral way that you can fit four of
those relevant circles exactly into this
area